bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour votre nuque mais pour
votre nouveau numéro de kiosques
qu'est ce que votre magazine culturel
sur 50 en ville et ses environs
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
16 décembre
invités emmanuel urban et arnaud joyet
du groupe yves lignon les joyeux urbains
ils fêtent leurs 20 ans avec un album
intégral de leurs chansons et une
tournée qui débutera le 16 janvier à
l'usiné à chapeaux de rambouillet mardi
15 décembre à avait lieu la soirée
d'inauguration des médailles du roi à la
librairie des princes du château de
versailles un partenariat entre la
maison arthus bertrand et le château de
versailles pour présenter une collection
de dix sept médailles inspiré des
collections d'époque
rencontre avec lucioles nouvelle étoile
de la pop électro la chanteuse sera de
passage à la batterie du bouillant pour
vendredi soir pour un concert teinté de
sons électroniques
l'aca nos premiers invités emmanuel
urban et bonsoir et arnaud joaillier
bonsoir des cheminots
je lui disais vous êtes membre du groupe
yvelinois les joyeux urbains qui fait
qui a fêté ses 20 ans alors on vous
plaît vous êtes 5 donc on salue
également david roquier manu riquier et
mathieu c est avant de prolonger les
présentations on voit tout de suite vous
découvrir en images sur les îles
les messieurs mais cette l1
peu après
oh
mega est certes auteur sympa fait péter
le sucre est là
fais moi un bon café
corps
dans la publicité
la police et les jeunes ont renoué le
dialogue tu verras que bientôt les gens
de ton
pfff falloir avant café
alors emmanuel je lui disais à votre
groupe a fêté ses 20 ans 20 ans de
rencontres artistes et qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait revenir sur le départ ouhlala
bah du coup ça fait ça remonte à loin
parce que c'était il ya vingt ans en
fait on fête les 20 ans mais on a déjà
eu 20 ans il ya quoi y un ou deux ans on
va être groupe c contre 84 cents 94 ou
et ayant 94
comment ça s'est passé on était non on
se connaissait depuis le lycée qu en
fait depuis donc depuis des années 90
c'est comme ça ouais gens contre les
autres en gros au lycée on a monté les
joueuses urbain donc de nos noms puisque
lors nos joyeux emmanuel urban est fait
tous les jours ben brik
quelle belle idée et puis après voilà ça
s'est fait naturellement comme ça des
amis qui jouaient ensemble dans une cave
est qu'ils avaient envie de s'amuser qui
joue de la musique alors arnaud en 20
ans forcément votre musique
votre rapport au spectacle et au théâtre
a forcément évolué dans quel sens dans
le sens du mieux j'espère dans le sens
du jeu sait pas dans quel sens a évolué
est ce que votre approche en fait du
spectacle ou de la musique s'est vu
transformé au fil des années mais
d'abord on en fait pour s'amuser
donc là il arrive à un moment une
problématique à tiens c'est mon métier
donc ça d'un coup ça me rapporte donc la
deuxième phase d'écriture elle devient
plus compliqué parce que d'un coup on se
consommer une pression sur les épaules
qui est de dire et c'est mon métier faut
que ce soit bien il faut pas que je
déçoivent
il ya un truc comme ça aussi on a fait
un truc au départ et puis on sur la
deuxième salle d'écriture on se dit et
ce serait bien qu'on déçoivent pas donc
il ya quand même effectivement déjà
quelque chose qui change qui changent
pardon à sa à ce moment là et puis et un
travail plus recherchés en fait au
niveau des textes c'est ça en tout cas
il ya une pression je sais pas si c'est
plus recherchés ou moins recherchés on
vous dit style vestimentaire aussi
peut-être que vous n'êtes plus savoure
aujourd'hui
ah oui ça c'est sûr la l'a pas vraiment
aimé mais parce que on est en tenue de
ville en commande il m'aimait sur san
luis et si vous avez regardé les petites
images avant il ya une certaine sobriété
où est-ce qu'on peut dire une classe je
ne sais pas pas pour tout le monde qu'il
ya alors emmanuel en fait pour 20 ans
vous avez fait le saut à n'ont pas de
sortir un best-of comme le font beaucoup
groupe mais un intégral pourquoi ce soit
parce qu'il ya pas mal de gens
qui ont les albums qu'ils ont plus haut
qu'ils ont prêté ou parce que voilà
comme tous les groupes indépendants on a
eu pas mal de soucis de distribution et
de commercialisation de nos albums et
même de sortie des fois que le dernier
en date ils feront pas sentir et du coup
ça permet aux gens qu'ils ont soit
cassée et soir y est soit c'était pas
des vignes et la tension n'est pas si
vieux que ça mais mais qu'ils ont perdus
on va enfin voir là bref ça le primaire
de ça permet de retrouver tout dans un
seul coffret à un prix très abordable il
semble puisqu'au dérisoire des risques
dérisoire parce que je crois que ça va
se vendre 25 euros pour pour les airs
pour les sorties albums album ouais un
poster ouais au prix de la chanson c'est
vraiment pas cher la chanson intégral
d'ailleurs qui sortira le 16 janvier
alors arnaud par contre vous démarrez
également le 16 janvier une tournée
une tournée qui sera pour le coup un
best-of
comment est ce que vous avez fait votre
sélection des titres par mail par mail
en partie dans mais on sait avec manu on
s'est vus et on a parlé par miles up
avec les autres qui sont pas aussi prêts
que nous vivons graphiquement même
amicalement tu peux le dire mais au cevu
on a on a mis tous les morceaux puis on
a rayé des trucs puis on a mis des croix
puis après un mini grosse croire en
disant je préfère à mai puis est arrivée
la liste de ce que j'aimerais vraiment
faire ce que je m'en fous ce que je veux
bien faire et et puis ce qu' il faut
faire deux hommes convaincre mises
d'accord question de préférence alors
cette tournée voulait démarrer à l'usiné
chapeau de rambouillet c'est un lieu qui
vous est cher oui oui carrément
parce que il ya des lieux comme ça où
quand on débute on se fait un petit peu
envoyer paître pour pas mal de gens et
donc on a joué on dit bon je vais dans
des abris bus de saint quentin en
yvelines pour tout dire et tellement
n'avaient pas de lieu pour jouer
qu'après on commence à faire des petits
bars mais voilà ça reste des barrages
aller tiba est ensuite offert mesure on
a pu jouer dans des salles et l'usinage
a posté une des premières à vraiment de
faire confiance à dire ok pour vous
démarrez c'est pas tout à fait au point
mais on va vous faire passer quand même
sur une première partie
et puis après ça
là c'est chez eux que ça ne démarrez
votre façon de leur rendre hommage et de
les remercier
alors du bahut sur dont vous n'êtes pas
les seuls à célébrer vos 20 ans cette
année
c'est également le cas du groupe imaging
groupe vocal du jazz in i montain ils
seront à la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux samedi soir à 20h30 pour un
concert qui retracera toute l'histoire
du jazz
on les écoute
et
c'est
c
g
m
emmanuel urban et arnaud joaillier merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau
aujourd'hui je rappelle que votre
intégral sort le 16 janvier prochain
date également du début de votre tournée
qui se fera à l' usine à chapeaux de
rambouillet et répétition générale
vendredi soir au scarabée
si vous nous louper l'usinage chapeau on
sera la celle saint cloud le relationnel
en semant le doute y seront bonnes mains
assure you et au point virgule à paris
si vous avez le courage n'a jusque là
très bien les rendez vous sont pris et
on poursuit cette émission avec
l'inauguration du cabinet des médailles
du roi à la librairie des princes du
château de versailles mardi 15 décembre
à un partenariat entre la maison arthus
bertrand et le château de versailles
pour présenter une collection de dix
sept médailles inspiré des collections
d'époque images de patrick jacques de
dixmude du sésame pour entrer dans les
jardins du trianon sous marie antoinette
aux décorations officielles des jeux
olympiques
les médailles ont toujours été des
témoignages de l'histoire frappé
poinçonnet doré et patiné les médailles
harbour différentes fonctions depuis
l'antiquité la médaille avait plusieurs
symboles s'il fit dire d'abord c'était
une manière assurée de pouvoir
retransmettre son image à la postérité
parce que c'était de préférence un
matériau inaltérable ensuite la médaille
pouvait être un outil de propagande à
partir d'un moment vous
mettez en avant vos victoires votre
famille et c'est également donc au type
de propagande complémentaires sachant
que lee médailles notamment les
médailles en or servait de cadeaux
diplomatiques
louis xiv fervent collectionneur de
médailles pour glorifier son règne avait
même aménagé son cabinet des médailles
au château de versailles en 1684 celui
ci aujourd'hui disparu le château a eu
l'idée de s'associer à la maison arthus
bertrand pour lancer une collection de
17 pièces hier avait lu dans la
librairie des princes du château
l'inauguration de cette collection nous
on est passionné de médailles on avait
depuis longtemps lui toute la
littérature autour du cabinet des
médailles du roi louis xiv est un grand
collectionneur et on est attaché à cet
art de la médaille on avait proposé au
château de versailles de reproduire pour
le château des médailles déjà anciennes
ou existantes dans les fonds du château
est en aussi en inventer on essaie de
faire un sans trêve et au château on
puisse rayonner un peu étrange et puis
avoir quelques ressources
complémentaires
l'idée c'était justement de reprendre
des médailles puis dé commercialiser au
j'avais dans tous les lieux historiques
des petites médailles à vendre pas cher
n'est pas forcément de très bonne
qualité
il sent forcément un grand lien
historique un moyen de créer des
ressources pour entretenir le château de
versailles tout en développant
l'économie des entreprises du patrimoine
tels que la maison arthus-bertrand des
maisons qui sent toutes les commandes de
restauration serait amené à péricliter
et viennent de nous rejoindre en plateau
luciole artiste auteur compositeur
interprète nouvelle étoile de la pop
électro poétique vous précisiez est
saisie dubreuil alors mesdames à toutes
les deux bonsoir lucioles c'est un vrai
plaisir de vous de vous retrouver ce
soir car je sais que vous êtes très
prise vous avez entamé une tournée à
travers la france et sur paris alors
vous venez de sortir également en mars
dernier un album qui s'intitule une je
propose qu'on en découvre tout de suite
un extrait
j'ai fait deux trois
oh
je suis
je
merci à plusieurs
pourquoi changer
je donne je vais
alors le monsieur le titre de votre
album une les particulièrement
symbolique pour vous expliquez nous will
est symbolique parce que bon déjà c'est
le titre d'une chanson et donc c'est
vrai que souvent quand on choisit un
titre dans pour pour son disque on va
aller d'abord regarder quelles sont les
chansons qu'on a écrite et quels sont
les sujets et finalement je trouvais que
cette chanson résumait bien la totalité
du disque qui était l'idée de rester
entier de rester un de rester une de
s'assumer comme on est
avec ses qualités ses défauts quand on
est en pleine mutation quand on passe de
la jeune fille à la femme
on est en chantier en construction est
forcément bas ont fait des choix qui
sont bons mauvais et l'idée c'est de les
assumer toujours de rester toujours une
entier alors justement je vous
présentais comme la nouvelle étoile de
la pop électro parce qu'on retrouve en
fait dit son électronique mais que vous
mêlez également à des guitares
acoustiques à des adducteurs et il ya du
saxo mais vous accordez justement une
importance aux textes sont il ya des
vraies chansons de textes que vous
composez tout
oui c'est le texte est vraiment le point
de départ la matière première c'est du
texte que va découler la mélodie et
ensuite la musique s'ajoutent et c'est
vrai que contrairement à mes projets
précédents on a introduit beaucoup plus
d'électro de sons électroniques dans ce
projet d'album là parce que envie de
oued de faire un pas vers la modernité
d'avoir un son qui me ressemblerait
davantage et qui peut aussi sur scène me
porter être plus dense plus volumineux
pouvoir faire danser les gens
aussi donc voilà parce que donc on ne
l'a pas précisé mais c'est votre
deuxième album il ya d'abord eu un
premier album un ep est donc là ce
deuxième album dont vous écrivez tous
vos textes et en fait il retrace une
sorte d'autobiographie d'introspection
de témoignages oui c'est je fasse je
sais écrire que ce que sur ce qui me
touche je saurai pas inventer des
histoires j'ai besoin ouais de de
regarder ce qu'il ya autour de moi le
temps qu'il fait les gens qui
m'entourent
ce que je peux ressentir et puis le
transposer en mots en essayant de faire
en sorte de rester suffisamment ouverte
pour que les gens puissent se
reconnaître et et par le prisme de leur
histoire se les approprient et ça marche
d'ailleurs plutôt bien pour vous parce
que la presse
en tout cas vous reconnaît un vrai
talent et vous avez donc entamé une
tournée de par la france et sur paris et
vous serez à la batterie de guyancourt
vendredi soir à 20 heures
qu'est ce que vous allez présenter
l'ensemble de vos titres je vais
présenter principalement des titres
issus du du dernier album avec un ou
deux un ou deux titres dont un ou deux
morceaux un plus notamment un tout
nouveau titre qui figure dans le dernier
album de grand corps malade qui vient
tout juste de sortir et donc que j'ai
intégré à mon spectacle parce que c'est
la dernière chanson en date écrite et
que le un spectacle ça se modifie
toujours
l'idée c'est de coller à ses envies
voilà mais oui ça va être une heure
encore plateau avec légalement bertrand
belin
je pense que ça va être une belle soirée
j'espère que les gens seront embarqués
dans ces deux univers la très différents
sans aucun doute
alors on va justement s'embarquer pour
un univers un petit peu différent avec
une exposition qui est actuellement
présentée au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux lésigny montain
écoles collèges et centres de loisirs
étaient invités à participer au concours
à remo jusqu'au 30 novembre
chacun était libre de proposer une
création sur des supports et matériaux
laissés à la discrétion des concurrents
une seule contrainte proposer une
création sur le thème de la liberté
l'exposition est présentée donc au
conservatoire jusqu'au 19 décembre
la remise des prix du concours a lieu ce
soir on écoute stéphanie gareau
responsable du pôle jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux fait c'est un concours qui
a lieu chaque année à la même période et
qui invite
des inimités de tout âge et aussi des
structures municipales ou associatives a
participé en créant une oeuvre à partir
d'un proverbe ou d'une citation de la
langue française
alors on poursuit cette fois ci avec une
autre exposition la vôtre cj du breuil
vous utilisez alors vous avez pour vous
présenter fait les beaux-arts et puis
vous avez il ya quelques années et vous
avez décidé à votre tour en fait
d'enseigner les arts plastiques
donc vous êtes devenu professeur vous
utiliser toutes les techniques à l'eau
en creux de gilles gouaches aquarelles
sur des formats allongé il ya une vraie
volonté d'utiliser ces formats oui
complètement et puis les techniques
aussi des t'écoute légère notre effort
nabeul voilà parce que vous expliquer
justement un rapport à la liberté
matt contre un tri ce n'est pas mal oui
oui et ses formes allongées c'est
justement pour recréer un espace temps
particulier le oui oui c'est l'idée de
temporalité dedans de permettre une
lecture et un déroulement en fête est
donc en fait on le voit à l'écran vous
proposer comme des frises donc c'est une
réflexion autour du déploiement du corps
dans l'espace
oui oui je suis en train de regarder
jouer c'est luce et vous vous en êtes
bel air oui et pourquoi justement
proposé cette cette réflexion autour du
déploiement du corps dans l'espace
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça
symbolise pour vous c'est surtout au
niveau de la boîte aussi en fait les
boîtes
c'est un peu mystérieux il peut y avoir
des secrets et en fait quand on ouvre
ces corps qui sortent un des danses de
vie mais ça peut être aussi des révoltes
déshérence c'est un rapport au mouvement
qui a oui et puis de groupements il fait
mr aussi les groupements éphémère
m'intéresse particulièrement
ce soit des des musiciens des objets
aussi des théâtre d'objets voilà et vous
accordez une importance comme musiol
importante à la lecture au mot et pour
vous était justement important d'être
exposée au sein d'une médiathèque pour
lui le rapport au livre trouve ça très
important c'est un espace de méditation
si la bibliothèque
ça permet des jeux vous en parler là des
voyages immobiles de se retrouver aussi
et tous les âges alors ça ça m'intéresse
aussi particulièrement c'est tous les
âges les enfants
voilà ça c'est insensé un carrefour un
carrefour est également vous avez de la
un rapport particulier à l'art un
rapport très conscient vous disiez qu'en
fait c'était une façon de s'inscrire
dans l'histoire de marley ensemble des
peintures de lascaux
parce que la peinture justement permet
de garder une trace au travers de
l'humanité d'avoir un rapport à l'autre
complètement
et puis aussi en fait on peut
s'apercevoir aussi des des êtres humains
qui sont morts il y a longtemps sont
peut-être quelques fois beaucoup plus
proche de vous que des gens vivent ça
c'est à fait étonnant hein
un peu le dialogue à travers le temps ça
ça m'intéresse
oui particulièrement oui c'est vrai que
la découverte des peintures rupestres ça
a été pour moi un grand choc
une rencontre oui au tce la tête par don
du ciel c'est parce que vous partagez ce
même rapport à l'art je ne sais pas si
je partage le même ce même rapport là
parce que chaque artiste a qu'ils soient
peintres musiciens comédiens
lee forcément
il ya forcément un lien étroit qui se
crée entre sa façon de le voir et et le
vivre mais je trouve ça juste
intéressant parce que j'aime entendre un
artiste parler de ce qu'ils aiment et de
ses son décryptage wall a fêté ses noces
et des sensibilités en fait donc josh la
tête parce que je trouve c'est toujours
intéressant de voir quelqu'un parler de
deux ce qui le passionne en fait tout
simplement c'est différent et en même
temps en référence
oui et puis c'est ses semblables parce
que c'est ce qu'on aime faire et que
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous anime
luciole cg dubreuil merci dame est
revenue sur notre gâteau aujourd'hui
alors je rappelle que nous pourrons
retrouver lucioles sur la scène de la
batterie vendredi soir à 20 heures pour
un concert et l'exposition de cj du
breuil à la médiathèque de voisins le
bretonneux jusqu'au 5 janvier vous avez
toutes les vacances donc pour en
profiter et comme chaque semaine votre
rubrique cinéma bien sûr alors avec
aujourd'hui la sortie nationale du
réveil de la force dernier star wars
tout de suite vos réactions au micro du
jérémy quesada scotch ou est ce que tous
fauté pendant 2h15 super ainsi par
moments c'est énorme et appuyé à 40 ans
de souvenirs et sur mon dos là
franchement c'était impressionnant
puis et beaucoup de à la fois du du
nouveau puits à la fois de ses
supérieurs je suis pas du tout déçu par
rapport par rapport au film c'était
vraiment vraiment très bien allez-y
alesi trop de clichés et de copier
coller peut-être des autres un peu comme
dans le même esprit qu'ils ont fait
jurassique world avec les anciens
jurassic park
ils ont réussi à trouver un scénario qui
nous tient en haleine et c'est vraiment
dans la suite du retour du jedi
on s'y retrouve complètement bien sûr
faut des repères comme pour se recaler
ça fait 30 ans qu'on dit gêné mais a
conseillé qu'il y avait un peu de
répétitions fait par rapport aux ans à
starz enfin il ya eu pas mal de clin
d'oeil mais en général mais t il était
bien un très bon rythme beaucoup
d'action en ce n'est pas pendant le film
puissant mon film toujours pour votre
rubrique cinéma cette semaine c'est
bertrand pigné du cinéma les huiles et
les adh de saint cyr l'école qui vous
donne son coup de coeur aujourd'hui on
ce 16 décembre 2016 alors que la force
se réveille partout sur la france au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa notre coup de
coeur ne va pas être star wars le réveil
de la force parce que nous n'aurons qu'à
partir du 30 décembre pendant les
vacances mais c'est un autre film un
film que nous avons déjà passé une
semaine et que nous continuons à
soutenir le film s'appelle l'hermine
c'est un film de christian vincent
réalisateur assez reconnu dans le monde
du cinéma français qui met en scène
fabrice luchini et 6e babette nude scène
qui est une actrice norvégienne qu'on a
pu voir dans la série borgen le film
s'appelle donc l'hermine
évidemment il nous parle d'un tribunal
d'un président de tribunal joué par
fabrice luchini et qu'ils rencontrent à
l'occasion d'un jury d'assises
une femme pour laquelle il a eu un coup
de foudre et qui elle n'avait pas
répondu à son coup de foudre à ce moment
là le film va donc mêlés et cette
histoire d'amour manquer ce rendez vous
manqué cet acte manqué et puis un grand
film de tribunal un grand film qui va
nous raconter ce qu'est la réalité d'un
jury d'assises pour l'occasion d'une
affaire un peu grave puisqu'il s'agit
d'une mort d'enfants mais c'est un film
d'une très grande beauté il a été
présenté à la mostra de venise cette
année il a gagné le prix du scénario et
c'est très méritée parce que c'est
décrit d'une manière très très belle et
puis fabrice luchini et ya gagné le prix
d'interprétation masculin on aime ou on
aime pas fabrice luchini il en fait
parfois trop là il est d'une sobriété
absolument fantastique il est très très
bon
il a répondu un mal être c'est celle ci
pour moi 2 qu'est ce que j'aurais pu
plus de monde
je commencerai par coup
si vous très touchant très intelligents
et qui vous touchera forcément alors je
vous invite à le retrouver encore cette
semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa et
puis d'attendre encore trois semaines
pour retrouver celui là et comme chaque
semaine avant de nous quitter je vous
propose quelques dates à noter dans
votre agenda culturel vendredi soir à
20h30 au théâtre espace coluche de
plaisir pour rendez vous pour la pièce
de théâtre la chanson de l'éléphant qui
a obtenu deux nominations aux molières
2014 et qui réunit pierre cassignard et
jean baptiste maunier on en regarde tout
de suite un extrait vigueur cjga vous la
personne reste en dehors de tout ça l
elysée et vicieuse
mais vous comprenez pas que les plus
intelligents de vaud le stade ci il me
faut une preuve concrète que vous savez
vraiment quelque chose au sujet du dr
lawrence est quelque chose qui n'a rien
à voir avec les aînés
1er - aucune trace rien de stupide
promet promet moult ulfa rien de stupide
retrouvez également les équipes d'impro
de déclic théâtre 1 à l'occasion de leur
premier match d'impro de la saison
samedi 19 décembre à 14 heures 30 pour
les benjamins 16 heures pour les cadets
et 20 heures pour les juniors à l'école
municipale de musique et de danse de
trappes et enfin rendez vous samedi 19
décembre également à 18 heures à la
ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt pour
retrouver un spectacle de danse jeune
public la forêt ébouriffés afin de
pénétrer un univers merveilleux fin du
kiosque pour cette émission je vous
retrouve avec plaisir à la semaine
prochaine émission à voir et à revoir
sur notre site internet
très bonne soirée à tous